TH FROM
DOWNTOWN. WANTED TO SEE THAT.
>>OM DOWNTOWN.
GOBERT, NO BOUNDS.
>> THAT'S BYTW
DRAWS THE DOUBLE TEAM.  STRONG.
HE HAS HAD A THREE INCREDIBLEONH
SPACE HE NEEDS TO GET THE OF
THESE
20-POINT LEAD.
LINE. IT OVER.
UP21 POINTS.
THAT WILL PUT
WIWITHTHININ S STRTRIKIKINING G.
SPSPERERO:O: TIED ATCLOCK.
>> WELL, WE ALL KNOW IN THE VI.
GOING TO WORK.
DOWN
CONLEY
DENNIS SCHRÖTHREES,
ANOTHER ONEA BUCKET AFTER
TRAILING BY TWO AFTER ONE.
>> Thurl: WATCH RUDY, THROW IT
ONCE BUT TWICE AND THE LEFTY RU
SUSTAINABLE. BUCKET.
>> UNGUARDIBLE WHEN YOU HAVE AN
FIVE ASSISTS.
>> GIDDY TO THE SCREEN.
RESULTED IN A TURNOVER. GET THE
RESPONSE.
GOBERT TIPPED IT
THERE AND YOU JUST WANT TO TAKE
IT
>> Craig:TONIGHT, ANOTHER
DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
AND THEY WILL HAVE TO HURRY.
SHOOTING, DOWN TO  THREE REBOUN.
OH,IM
THE FIRST THREE TIMES IN THIS
GAME.
HE BOUNCES IN DOESN'T WANT TO
GOBERT!BEHINDD
DONOVAN FROM REBOUND
AWAY. TIMING.
AGAIN, DON'T EVEN